first of all what is who is Billy
Eilish I have no clue this girl is
clearly an MKULTRA vet she every video
she's like bleeding out of her eyes
they're all like rituals and I'm not
even that guy yeah they come out even
that guy that's like look at the
symbolism why is Taylor Swift you know
right you know in a fire what does that
mean why is Katy Perry in hell in this
video but like you look at the Billy
Eilish video and it's like these weird
rape fantasies come to life
she's bleeding on every horse of orifice
like this blue black blood what the [ __ ]
is going on like I don't want to see him
unhappy I don't want to seem uncool cuz
I want to be you know woman forward
Satan forward but what the [ __ ] going
on yeah what is happening I don't know
the girl has the energy of somebody that
Harvey Weinstein kept in a cage and
raped for ten years and everyone thinks
it's great yeah she's on Ellis she
doesn't even sing she just murmurs she's
like I'm a bad little kids these little
kids are like thinking it's great yeah I
like Billy I want to get raped into Fame
come on come on I'm a bad guy come and
get me yeah mr. senator mr. studio head
come and find me put me in the middle of
his pentagram and introduce me to the
dark lord I will be impregnated with
Satan and then there it's like what is
this yeah and by the way that's amazing
about black versus white when you're
black like Liz oh she's up there she's a
big girl she's singing dancing and
playing a [ __ ] fluid yeah
this chick just showed up and went I
love Satan and they're like gasps patch
millionaire
yeah millionaire yeah Liz O's been
singing for like years and years and
years this one
just shows up like she was wandering
down a highway with blood all over her
like she just escaped the shed and true
detective
and then she's you know and she's on the
view huh yeah and I you know I don't
want to sound unhip and uncool because I
don't get what's clearly something's
wrong yeah something's wrong there
Billy's not gonna I don't think Billy is
even gonna make it to Amy Winehouse I
like it's a problem
something's going on yeah I don't want
to seem maybe I'm wrong have you seen
her I've seen his pictures of her yeah
she looks like little zan but like a
girl she looks like little Zab but she
little Zen I get a wholesome about my
statutes I get a wholesome vibe from
little zan here like I don't think
little zan could spell Satan right so I
think he's kind of like a teddy bear
he's a lovable yeah I think sounds a
simple man zan just wants a
pharmaceutical yeah a bag of cheetos and
like a soft chair to like slink in and
like make noises that are kind of words
right well he's like y'all a mean you
know a lady you like you know yeah like
that's what I think yeah I don't know I
don't get the dark vibe from Jean I mean
it is I guess dark in the sense that he
can barely speak or move most times I
see him but that's the kids that's the
kids nowadays you can't you don't want
to start like a boomer respect these
kids I know you have to like everything
you have to like everything that
children do yeah yeah you have to let
children lead the way even if they're
clearly on drugs you have to being
violently raped yeah
by members of the music industry they
should still lead the way yeah what is a
kid what are the kids think about global
warming come here yeah blinky
blinky the autistic yeah rapper what do
you think well you know a planet [ __ ]
you have to call yourself an old-timer
if you're like 27 or like hey I don't
know about this young generation I'm my
age people people think I'm in my 30s
and I keep telling people I'm [ __ ] 18
and they don't believe me because the
[ __ ] stupid I just graduated a school
okay I just graduated [ __ ] high
school and it was a [ __ ] dope year
and I went to the prom with Billy Eilish
and we we we caught a baby out of some
woman's womb in the problem it was a
prank it was a prank whatever but like
the head of Capitol Records or whatever
Capitol Records is now was there and he
made us do it and then he hit the baby
and I don't know he kept talking about
you know the one true forced it animates
all things darkness
whatever prey but the prom was fun you
know
we listen to me ghost we listen to cardi
B you know we had a great time